and that police strategy now being
deployed to remove demonstrators is
unlike anything seen in recent memory
from other large-scale protests it began
as a slow coordinated effort to push
protesters out but that situation now
appears to be shifting our ottawa bureau
chief mercedes stevenson spent much of
the day on the ground amid the protest
and she joins us now so mercedes how
would you describe the police tactics
that you saw out there today
well jeff earlier in the day they were
not dressed in tactical gear they were
at the front lines just in soft hats and
normal police clothing there were layers
of security back behind them including
the public order and mounted units that
we're now seeing come forward this
evening and finally the emergency
response team and tactical teams behind
that so a layered approach but
essentially they were trying to push
protesters back this came after
arresting as mike mentioned a number of
the leaders which was designed to
demoralize them the hope was that they
could convince people to leave if they
simply pushed them away and took away
the leadership there was a desire to try
to do this with as few arrests as
possible from what i'm hearing because
every arrest as you can imagine is a lot
of paperwork and also the desire was to
take back the area and then hold it so
that people couldn't get back into those
trucks we are seeing that evolve over
the evening as this is becoming much
more confrontational after a lot of the
people who have chosen to leave have
left and what you're getting is the
people who are truly entrenched at this
point but in terms of what the overall
police strategy looks like we talked to
vern white he's a senator now but he's
also the former chief of police here in
ottawa here's what he had to say
i think it's about moving down taking
space each time you go down take that
space from them remove the people who
are refusing to leave hopefully enticing
a large number that you know what i came
here for protest i didn't come here for
jail i certainly didn't come here for a
criminal record and a lot of those
people helped them get out of the city
mercedes given the slow speed of the
operation so far how long is this
enforcement effort expected to take
that's a great question it was super
slow this morning and it seems to be
speeding up significantly tonight as the
police is using the mounted unit to try
to push people back but i spoke to jim
bremner he's the head of the canadian
tactical officers association about how
long he thinks this could take take a
listen to what he has to say
it's going to be inch by inch and it's
going to be based on
again each individual and how they want
to acquiesce
i'm i'm going to say we're probably a
week away
to clearing this because it's going to
take
uh you know at least an hour hour and a
half to clear each vehicle
now at this hour jeff a number of
vehicles have cleared off of wellington
which police sources were telling me
were going to be the most difficult part
of the street to clear so so that may
take a little bit less time but
certainly this is a very fluid situation
and it's evolving very rapidly but the
police are hoping to do this with as
little violence as possible and i'm sure
some of the protesters are hoping for
that too
all right mercedes-stevenson in ottawa
thanks